次のセクション瞑想実践もまず体だから
それで瞑想する場合でも
まず体から瞑想始まりますよ
煩悩完全に達す 瞑想実践も体を観察することで始まるんです
だから体を無視することはできないんです
そこでヴィパッサナー瞑想は四念処経で書いてますから
第一はカーヤヴィパッサナーでしょ
身住念というセクションですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想はセットでできてます
身住心法という位置は体から
ヴィパッサナー瞑想は心理をありのままに観察することです
最初は体を観察する それは具体的でわかりやすいんです
瞑想しやすいんです これは体の瞑想なんですよ １
アナパーナパッブ このパッブという言葉はこの経典の中にあるんじゃなくて
経典の編集するとセクションにだいたい入れている言葉なんです
いっそ入れたかさっぱりわかりませんだけど
まぁとにかく経典にはその言葉あります
いわゆる呼吸編 呼吸を観察する
それも体の観察なんです 2
番目はイリアアパタパッブ
行住捨編 歩いたり座ったり立ったり横になったりする時の観察
実況中継 ３サンパジャーナパッブ招致編
ということは 食べる 飲む
着替えたりする 手足を伸ばしたりする
しゃがんだりする 物を取ったりする
いろんなことをやっているでしょう
そういう行住捨以外の体の行為も実況中継でやることなんです
一応瞑想宿泊瞑想に行っている方々には
一応そういうふうにやってくださいとは一応言ってはおきます
その方が正しいんだから見事に守らないということになります
まぁ一応我々はそういうところは全部言ってはあります
ある人が私の瞑想というのは経典と随分違いますねと言ったんですけど
蹴っ飛ばしたかったんですけどね
で サンパジャーナパッバっていうのは
まぁもう何か取ったり飲んだり
左見たり 右見たり 上見たり
いろんな体の動きを実況中継でやることなんです
これ３つ  4番目はパティックーラマニカーラ
付除栽編という 栽というのはわざと念じることなんです
だから実況中継 ちょこっと変わるんですよ
1番目は体の三十二の部分を付条として分けて観察する
その場合は昔のお坊さんだったら
このアッティー ケーサーローマ
ナカダンタータチョーマンサンナハルーアッティーアッティーミンジャーワッカハデイアカネキローマカンピーカンパッパサンアンタンアントブナンウディーリアンカ
リーサンピッタンシッマンプッボーリータンセドメドアッスーワサーケーローシンガーニカーラシカンムッタンという三十二なんです
それは体のケーサーというのは髪の毛
ローマというのは体の毛
ナカーというのは爪 ダンターというのは歯
タチョーというのは皮膚
マンサンというのは肉
ナハルーというのは血管
アッティーというのは骨
アッティーニンジャーというのは骨髄
ワッカンというのは腎臓
ハデアン心臓 キローマカンというのは肝臓
パッパサンというのは肺
それを 1個肺だけ取ってみると気持ち悪いんですよ
感想を見ても 人間の牛の豚の肝臓だったら食いたくなるかもしれませんだけど
人間の肝臓はね 気持ち悪くなるんです
で その場合はそのただ肝臓
肝臓 肝臓とイメージを作ってでもよろしいし
遺体で肝臓を一つ持ってきたってもよろしいし
それを観察するんですよ
5番目ダートマニカーラ
元素 元素ですけど 仏教では貝と読むんですね
貝栽編 ということは この肉体が地水火風で構成しているんだと思って
あ これは地 これは水 これは風
そういう風に観察する
例えば血液やら尿やら
それは水 呼吸やらそれは風
それから手足動くことも風というエネルギーにしているんです
そういう風にもうこの 4つに分けてみるということで
何のことないんではないか
それは体でしょうということになるんです
それから体の瞑想  6から14まではナワシーヴァティカーパッバンと言うんです
ココナッツのつかまへん
意味は簡単 遺体が朽ちていく ９
つの段階を観察するんです
それには生の遺体がないとできないんですね
で 遺体捨て場で遺体捨てていると 1
日目から3日目までは一つで体膨らんでくる
それからもう青くなってきてくる
それからあっちこち穴が開けて膿が出始める
それからウジ虫がいっぱい出て
口から出てくるわ 目からウジ虫が出てくるわ
いろんなところからウジ虫が出てきたりするし
次に動物たちが来てあっちこち食べるんだからね
ぐちゃぐちゃになった肉
臭い ものすごい悪臭の遺体があると
それを見る それでどんどん肉肉がなくなっちゃって
筋だけ残って 骨が硬くなって筋だけである
それから筋もどんどん微生物に食べられて骨が壊れていく
その状態を見る それからやがてまた誰かが骨を全部固めてひと塊にする
それを観察する それからその骨も雨に降られて
どんどん白くなって粉になっていくこと
土に戻ることを観察するという９のステージがあります
で 現在はやるのは無理ですけど
そこも入れちゃうと全部 14の体の修行になります
これらは具体的 合理的な智慧の開発方法で
微塵でも修行は入ってません
痛い見ることは苦行ですかね
見るだけだから 一つも苦行じゃないんです
お墓 墓場に遺体を見る
観察瞑想するために行くお坊さんも
ちゃんとご飯食べて しっかり体を洗って
沐浴をして ちゃんと衣を着て
髪の毛を剃って しっかりした人間で行くんです
行ってずっと遺体のところで座っているんです
見ながら実況しながら
ちゃんと実況しながらいかないんですよ
例えばそういう遺体を見て実況すれば
今膿が出ている遺体ですと
私の体も死んだらこのようになります
どんな人の体も死んだらこのようになります
執着には値しない そのリストで言うんです
我々やっている実況中継とは微妙に変わります
それから体から心へ瞑想を持っていくんです
体の瞑想が進むと 自然に感覚に集中するようになる
感覚を理解していくと
心の働きが見えてくる
心の働きを理解していくと
自然に普遍的な真理 ダンマを見えてくる
残りの3つ どんどんどんどん心の方に入っちゃうんです
ダンマっていうのは四聖諦
無常 無我などですね それ見えてくるんです
結果として悟りに達する
だから仏教も体から瞑想始まりますが
微塵も苦行はないんです
それから別の名前書いてある
本当の仏道って何なのかと
八正道は中立 中正 中正
中正  2つも この中正っていうのは理性ですね
的な正真正銘の仏道です
仏道といえば八正道なんです
なのに仏教はもう苦行でしょうと
初期仏教とテーラワーダ仏教で大乗仏教はとても楽ですよとか
そんなことをよく言う
では八正道にどこらへん苦行でしょうかと見てみましょうか
何か苦行あったら言ってください
正しい見解 これ苦行ですかね
正しい思考 思考を直すことは苦行ですかね
正しい言葉を語ること
正しい行為をすること
正しい職業っていうのは苦行ですかね
それから正しい動力 努力
どこら辺に苦行ありますかね
それから正しい観察 何か苦行ありましたね
じゃあ 8番目 正しい心を統一する
落ち着く どこに苦行ありますかと
八正道の中で 八正道が正真正銘の仏道なんです
いかにかっこよくて立派なものかというと
今日は残念ながらこの８の説明には入る時間はないんです
それで仏教の八正道というのは
知識から理解することから智慧へ進むんです
苦行と関係ないんです
八正道の一と二は 人は最初に育てるべき理解
知識 思考のことになります
3 4 5は理性に基づいた生き方
道徳です 理性に基づいた生き方
6は人格なこと 人格的なこと
生けす成長するために努力することです
だから 6番目は人格  7と8は智慧を開発する方法
だから理性から智慧へという道なんです
知識から智慧へ しっかりと整理整頓して順番で語っています
この順番が誰にも変えることできないんです
これは偉大なるお釈迦様が決めた順番なんです
好き勝手にするんじゃないんです
だから正見から始まるんです
頭をしっかりすること
例えば なんでこういう講演なんか聞いたりするかというと
頭をしっかりするためなんです
あ そういうこと 仏教かと
なるほど それが正見なんです
知らなかった なるほど
そういうこと 仏教か そうやってわかること
正見なんですよ それから正思惟になっちゃうんです
仏教で言われるように考え方を調整する
それから言葉やらあれこれやとやればいいんです
したがって 苦行には立場がありません
八正道では それで一つのセクションが終わって
最後のセクションに入ります
修行者への注意 これは皆様のことで
現代のことで 自己流になると悟れない
微妙にでも仏教は自己流になると悟れませんよ
悟ったのはブッダですから
ブッダが言う通りにやるしかないんです
ですから ブッダに忠実に
仏道は束縛の道ではなく
自由になる道なのです
わがまま 好き勝手 主観的な生き方は自由ではなく
病気なのです 仏教は自由だから
じゃあ我儘でいいんでしょうかと
我儘は病気です 好き勝手っていうのは病気です
真理に従うことこそが真の自由です
それから存在を脱出するんです
それが自由ということなんです
あの法則に従うんです
例えば 学校で校則がありますよ
あ 校則で縛られているんだとか思って
我儘で生きていると なおさら苦しいんですよ
校則破ると犯人扱いされます
異常者扱いされます 何のことなく
まあ校則もちゃんと守っていると自由なんです
そんなことじゃあまあいいわって感じでいれば
まあダメと言ってるんだから
まあ別なことを考えましょうと
校則に入らないいたずらを考えましょうと
ということで 自由っていうのはそういうものなんです
従う我々真理に従う それから存在を脱する
修行の方法を調整する場合は
心が成長するか否かは決まり手になるのです
だから 自分の個人の修行を微妙に調整しなくちゃいけないんですよ
調整するときの基準は何でしょうかというと
これで本当に私の心は成長するんでしょうかということなんです
成長するならば OK です
調整したものである程度で成長して
そこでガクンと止まったら
すぐそれをまた変えなくちゃいけないんです
時々私に聞く場合はありますからね
こうやってますけど それでよろしいでしょうかとか
聞く瞬間でこっちには読めますよ
この方法だったらどこまで行くのかということは
しかし 私は素直にハイとノーとも言わないんです
なぜかというと 相手の気持ちはその人よりも読んでいるんだからね
時々厳重にこの方法で俺がやってやるぞという気持ちで
これはやめた方がいいんだよと
なぜならば もう回向衆になりかねないんだから
だいたいそうじゃなくて
時々今私は歩く瞑想 こういう風にちょこっと変えたんだけど
いかがでしょう 私はなんで変えたの？変えたのは普通やっていてもなかなか心が落ち着かなくて
それで私はこういう風にやったところで
なんとなく落ち着いて
妄想は減りますと そういう機能あったら
まあそこまでやってくださいと
しかし その機能がなくなった時点でやめてくださいと
やめて元のやり方に戻ってくださいと
ですから この成長するかしないかということが決まり手なんです
すごい時間はなくなりました
人の話 学者の見解などには乗らない
決して 特に学者の見解っていうのは
他宗教の行を導入しない
いくらかっこよくても
他宗教の行を導入してはいけないんです
今までの習慣も仏教に適合しない場合はきれいさっぱりやめるんです
たとえ日本文化とかね
もう 4000年の歴史でやっているんだからとか
なんとかどうでもいいんで
ブッダの話に適合しないときれいさっぱりやめなさいと
世間の無知に従うのではなく
理性的な考えのみを聞くんです
世間の話を聞くんだけど
理性的な考えだけを聞くんですよ
みんな無知でアホで言ってることにセーフ乗るでしょうね
それはやめるんです 人の真似を自分の成長に役に立つならば使用する
人の真似をしてもいいんだけど
それで自分の成長するかないか
成長するならばちょこっと真似してみたってもいいんです
しかし 真似っていうのは
人の真似っていうのは人イコール先輩なんです
だから皆様も瞑想すると人の真似してもいいんだけど
俗世間の人間の真似じゃないんです
仏道の先輩の真似なんです
ブッダの瞑想方法であっても
勝手にいくつかの方法を混ぜないことです
ブッダがいろんな瞑想を教えています
今もぐらい体の瞑想を教えたでしょう
でも全部できないでしょ
もうお分かりでしょ？お墓の行はできないし
もうできないものありますよ
それ一個一個のやり方
また違いますよ できないんだから紹介してないんです
で 実況中継だけでは済まない
例えばお墓行とかね で
三十二の不浄行やってる場合でも
修行の場合でも 実況中継は微妙に変わったり変わらなかったり
いろいろあります 例えば心臓
心臓 心臓で実況したっても
何の心にも影響なくなっちゃうと
我々は別バージョン持ってます
やり方はもう暗記させますよ
三味の時はそういうのは
だからもうこの人知らない
この人すごい自慢げに言いますけどね
私は知らないふりをしていますからね
本当はまあ三味の時暗記させます
三十二の瞑想法とかね
でもそれと皆様がなさっているヴィパッサナーには
やり方的に方法的にはやり方が違いますよ
目的は同じですけど 悟ることが目的だからね
ですから いろんなものを混ぜちゃうと
勝手にブッダの瞑想であっても
勝手に混ぜるなよ 危険だよと
仏教の瞑想の場合も合成できるセットがあるので
指導者のアドバイスを聞いた方がベターです
瞑想をいくつか合成できるものも
合成できないものもありますよ
瞑想っていうのは 人の性格を見て教えているんですよ
性格っていうのはお互い似ていないんです
性格種類ですから 基本的に似ていない
それに合わせた瞑想だから
例えば 欲張り性格に教える瞑想と
怒りっぽい性格に教える瞑想と一緒にならんでしょうね
だから合成できるセットあるんですよ
それは指導者に聞くしか個人では決められません
好みで修行しないこと
例えば超能力 神通が欲しいなど
いろいろ好みでやるんじゃないんです
解脱したいと思うのは構いませんが
足かせになる恐れもあります
解脱したいという気持ちは悪くないんですが
それさえも足かせになる場合があります
はい では どのように瞑想すればいいかということ
修行 修行の衝動ですね
より具体的に目的を作るんです
よりわかりやすく 心を清らかにしたい
悪をなくしたい だらしない感情的な人格を何とかしたいと
苦しみを乗り越えたいと
できるところまで成長していきたいんだと
そんな目的だったらすごい具体的です
できるところまでやってやろうではないかとかね
解脱解脱ではないんです
それでうまくいきます
などの心構えで成長するんです
これが悟れるための 悟りたければ
こんな心構えでやるんです
はい そんなところやと思います
今日のお話は では ありがとうございます
ちょうど時間は過ぎましたけど